avec dominique bruillot patrimoine
découverte rencontré évasion nous
emmener ou bien au château de joux est
un monument incontournable de la franche
comté
oui je fais un petit point gps
oui parce que ce qui corrige pas le
château de joux forcément on est aux
portes de pontarlier à peu près dans un
rayon de 50 kilomètres il ya champagnole
salins les bains les rousseau suis même
pas très loin de bijoux en son nom bien
sûr il ya neuchâtel et lausanne aussi en
suisse on et voilà les points gps pour
bien qu'on comprenne oui alors le seul
château bas surtout déjà il n'est pas
situé n'importe où et des dix fier à
l'entrée de ce qu'on appelle la clusaz
de pontarlier quatre jours était un
point d'observation et de vigilance
assez fort puisque sans que césar lui en
parler dans la guerre des gaules et
évoquait déjà une fortification avec une
cinquantaine d'hommes qui était capable
de faire des miracles mais la réalité du
château elle entend que édifice elle
remonte quand même une dizaine de
siècles
c'est un petit pépère il ya un peu plus
de 2000 habitants et surtout il n'a
cessé de d'évoluer au fil du temps et on
peut considérer que c'est sans doute en
france l'un des sites les plus les plus
intéressants pour observer qu on
constater l'évolution de l'architecturé
militaire au fil des siècles depuis
l'époque médiévale jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on est au sommet d'un éperon rocheux d'à
peu près 1000 m ben oui on est au sommet
de plein de choses en fait et puis à la
croisée des chemins de tous les chemins
c'est à dire les chemins qui qui menait
aussi bien le
la défense de la champagne à l'italie le
qui relié le la vallée de la saône et la
bourgogne à la suisse fera tout ça donc
ça a été source de plein conflit alors
je n'aurai pas la prétention aujourd'hui
de retracer tous ces conflits parce que
la richesse historique du château de
joux est absolument phénoménale le but
de la chronique aujourd'hui c'est nous
montrer aussi qu'il ya une double vie
très intéressante dans ce château et on
va découvrir juste avant on peut
peut-être entrer à l'intérieur parce
qu'il ya un escalier en colimaçon qui
est quand même assez particulier une
belle découverte
on le voit là alors alors il ya
différents angles si vous allez faire un
petit tour sur internet vous allez voir
que vous avez différentes photos
possibles
alors surtout il ya voyez au milieu il
ya un monde charles week et date de
naissance à la monte charge vous pouvez
tout à fait mais tout à fait là c'est
assez intéressant parce que c'est là
alors il ya 2 il ya deux escaliers
l'escalier à vis que vous voyez avec son
monte charge qui laissant à 30 mètres
sous terre quand même voilà mon fameux
escalier manceau et puis il ya un autre
mine et attrapes amovible c'est à dire
que c'était aussi un piège
va t on pouvait le désosser comme ça au
fur et à mesure pour arrêter l'ennemi en
cas de l'agression donc tout et tout est
construit autour de la stratégie
militaire dans ce château
il ya plein d'autres choses à voir les
fossés c'est que le pont le billet
escamotable le chemin couvert en fait si
vous voulez parfaire votre éducation
militaire on est loin de la méditation
je suis désolé il faut tout moment mais
exactement il faut peut-être les
militaires entre deux batailles
oui oui je pense que les aider à tenir
le choc
bon 2 ea sports en une où vous allez me
dire mais pour l'instant on n'a vu
qu'une histoire mais il ya une autre
histoire il ya une autre histoire autour
d'un personnage célèbre
on est resté dans le secteur histoire de
se poser un petit peu avant de revenir
dans ce château
direction la suisse finalement je vous
emmène à bâle pour une histoire d'eau
vous allez comprendre
[Musique]
à bâle tout cela coule de source
sautez dans une fontaine trouver
facilement de l'eau pour se rafraîchir
la population évolue dans une ville
d'eau avec 213 fontaines publiques aux
petits soins d'une équipe spécialisée
qui entretient réparé nettoie ses
équipements historique
bâle a même son maître des fontaines en
suisse on devient maître des fontaines
en suivant une formation spécifique et
diplômante le maître des fontaines est
responsable du contrôle de l'eau potable
et des fontaines publiques
alex danzer coordonne le travail de six
personnes à temps plein et toute l'année
le municipal et distribué 365 jours par
an dans les fontaines de l'eau potable
la même que celle du robinet une eau
sous contrôle des services d'hygiène
fraîcheur et qualité sont garantis dans
la vieille ville mais aussi dans les
quartiers grâce notamment à ses
fontaines basilique balle en compte une
trentaine
le modèle est le résultat d'un concours
réalisé au 19e siècle il est devenu un
symbole de la ville
l'accès à l'eau potable partout et à
toute heure une évidence pour les
habitants une belle découverte pour les
gens de passage
pour nous les bâlois c'est complètement
normal on n'y pense même plus le fait
qu'on qu'ils jugent comme savoir l'autre
chez nous j'estime que c'est une chance
historique
j'en suis reconnaissant boire et se
rafraîchir dans le bassin du coin de la
rue l'autre exception culturelle de
balle car les fontaines sont autant de
piscines où il est parfaitement admis de
se baigner à quelques exceptions près
est lié à des considérations techniques
fontaine fraîcheur fontaine détente qui
se fait parfois annexe du bureau les
bâlois ont depuis longtemps adopté la
fontaine attitude
la fontaine c'est du rafraîchissement du
lien social avec les amis de la détente
on mange ensemble on se baigne ça fait
partie de balle comme la baignade dans
le rhin une tradition qui ne provoque
pas de débordements à bâle un héritage
bienvenus lorsque le thermomètre n'en
finit pas de grimper et vous l'aurez
constaté l'eau coule à flots à bâle dans
les plus de 200 fontaine quand même qui
se trouve à bâle on n'était pas très
loin de chez nos finalement en suisse on
va revenir dans le doubs du côté de ce
château à la cluse et mijoux précisément
au château de joux dans le doubs avec
cette double actualité si j'ose dire le
lieu d'abord le château de joux donc et
puis à l'intérieur un personnage surtout
déjà une prison c'était une prison
d'état pendant quelques décennies et et
jusqu'à lier la la déconfiture dans la
fin de napoléon 1er et quelques
personnages célèbres ayant été
emprisonnés ont résonné mais là en plus
une prison froide humide une prison qua
non la prison de prison je pense qu'on
était dans le désert le côté le plus
sévère de la prison il ya eu mirebeau
entre autres été emprisonné et puis
surtout et voilà c'est le beau gosse qui
joue et toussaint louverture alors un
destin absolument extraordinaire c'est
un à la base
à l'origine c'était un esclave affranchi
qui a mené
il est originaire de saint domingue
haïti pas confondre avec l'autre saint
domingue et il a pris les armes contre
les colons français avec l'aide des
espagnols dans un premier temps et puis
alors l'histoire se retourne souvent et
après il a pris le il a rejoint le camp
français compte les espagnols plus
tarder à faire cesser son histoire est
absolument incroyable surtout c'est
devenu le premier général noir le
couleur noir français et alors il a été
emprisonné sur ordre de napoléon
bonaparte pour s'être opposé à akwa
l'esclavagé des noirs bah oui parce que
benoît napoléon a rétabli
rétabli l esclavage en 18 ans je crois
et du coup lui c'est à nouveau retourner
contre napoléon et ont volé sa peau et
on l'a coincé et d'ailleurs il a fini à
l'âge de 60 ans il s'est éteint quelques
mois avant l'abolition définitive de
l'esclavagé
le pauvre on dit de lui vous m'arrêtez
si je me trompe qu'il était un petit peu
le symbole tu peu comme l'était martin
luther king nelson mandela enfin ou
d'autres de l'émancipation des peuples
mais alors c'était un fin politique en
fait sa force réside aussi dans le dans
sa capacité à wind qu'attristée
intellectuelle intéressante et c'était
un fin politique c'est à dire qu'il
savait à la fois longue mais avec la
situation sur le terrain militaire et en
même temps même année de la une
politique très concrètes
ar je précise qu'on retrouvera
d'ailleurs oui ça c'est lui le au
château de joux dans le doubs donc à la
cluse et mijoux qui a aussi une visite
guidée de la maison de la négritude
c'est important d'en parler si vous
souhaitez pourquoi pas un jour ou
l'autre nous poser d'autres questions
sur des lieux comme vous venez de le
faire là sur le château de joux ce qu'on
a découvert un lieu et un personnage
moi je vous renvoie sur le réseau social
par exemple facebook ou tout simplement
le numéro de téléphone qui s'affiche sur
votre écran voilà le 0 805 383 383 où
les matins de france 3 bourgogne franche
comté